meanwhile today in Manchester security
is being ramped up for Sunday's benefit
featuring Coldplay Miley and so many
more
the Royals haven't said if they will
attend but Prince William is in
Manchester visiting police and the
injured at a Children's Hospital
[Applause]
also today ABC and freeform announced
they will air Sunday's Onelove
Manchester show here in the u.s. live on
freeform at 2:00 p.m. Eastern
highlights on ABC after the NBA Finals
this as benefit performers were making
their way to the venue Katy Perry made a
pit stop in Paris today Biebs will leave
from New York and also making their way
it's going to be emotional because it
said it
we spoke exclusively with the Black Eyed
Peas today in Wales where they are also
taking the stage tomorrow night without
Fergie after rumors tickle Scherzinger
would replace her in the group is Fergie
so part of Black Eyed Peas
yeah so no one's replacement for you um
Fergie has a dream and we support her
dreams Fergie
working on a solo album tweeted her
support she won't be there Sunday but
the peas have worked out their setlist
[Music]
we need where's love right now will you
guys be performing that song I'm sundae
yes well we might also hear it tomorrow
because the peas are kicking off a huge
soccer match in Cardiff so you wife a
Champions League final it's actually the
most watched sporting event to the world
yeah that's even bigger than Super Bowl
[Music]